what up space fam golden here from anime
upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss another one piece video this
time i'm discussing the most hyped
subcategory of devil fruits one even
more rare than mythical zones that's
right today i'm discussing god fruits
and all users of said god fruits if you
do enjoy these one piece videos and want
to keep them coming you know what to do
channel parking within and smash that
like button be a smashing power king
rather than passing orochi and rumor has
it you'll get fireworks straight from
wano to your screen make this video
subscribe if you haven't already and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you won't miss future
one-piece videos and updates and now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all so as i mentioned this
is not just another video about mythical
zone fruits i already made a video on
all of those link in the description
here we're going beyond just mythical
and talking about actual gods and
deities of myth rather than just
mythical creatures a quick example of
what i mean is pegasus the flying horse
and zeus are both mythical figures but
pegasus is just a mythical creature
while zeus is a mythical god or deity
similarly i'm only covering fruits that
are based on figures that have been
labeled gods or deities let's start off
with yamato and the inuino no me model
okuchi no makami inu means dog and the
rest of the name means largemouth true
slash pure god in other words we could
just view it as a wolf god fruit
specifically in the series it is
referred to as a guardian deity
associated with guarding wano
specifically the makami is the
deification of the now extinct japanese
gray wolf which was worshiped as a
guardian of humans in japan it is
associated with protecting the good and
punishing the wicked with protecting
people against evil especially from
hardships caused by fire and robbery as
a result it makes a lot of sense that
yamato's powers are associated with ice
an element that did well to counter the
dangers of kaido's blast breath and also
of contrast fire some ice wolf god
attacks include namuji glacier fang
yamato's ice equivalent of kaido's blast
breath it's truly impressive that the
attack is strong enough to cancel out
kaido's blast breath then there's mirror
mountain a defensive technique that
allows the user to surround themselves
with ice in order to defend themselves
from an attack yamato used this
technique to defend against kaido's
attack and besides the ice cracking and
breaking off like glass yamato seemed
unharmed by the strongest creature's
attack hollowed glacier slash allows the
user to surround their weapon with ice
powers increasing its force yamato used
this to knock kaido down despite the
fact that kaido used his own weapon to
try to block the attack aside from named
attacks ice wolf god users can freeze
opponents create walls of ice to protect
themselves and even help protect bombs
from going off by surrounding them with
layers of protective ice the fact that
the attack names in japanese reference
gods like namoji being a reference to a
japanese deity and himorogiri being a
pun on himorogi which refers to sacred
altars used for kami worship also helps
to solidify this fruit's position as a
god fruit strength-wise yamato was able
to hold off kaido the so-called
strongest creature in the world and the
yonko with the largest bounty at the
time for a significant amount of time a
very impressive and noteworthy feat if
yamato and the wolf god fruit didn't
stay behind in wano it's hard to believe
that the other remaining forces would be
able to hold off such powerful threats
number two is kaido and his
me model serious this fruit lets him
transform into the azure dragon in
chinese myth the azure dragon is
considered one of the dragon gods so as
with yamato's fruit the word god or
deity is specifically used in reference
to kaido's devil fruit which is a big
thing we're looking for when deciding
what fruits deserve to be in this
category and it's not surprising that
kaido has one of the few god fruits when
we take into account that it's probably
one of the big reasons he gained the
title of the strongest creature in the
world just as yamato is able to
transform into a wolf or human wolf
hybrid kaido is able to transform into a
dragon or dragon human hybrid notably
kaido's fruit is a mythical model of the
fish fish fruit suggesting that it's a
reference to dragon gate myth where if a
carp or koi makes it to the top of an
almost impossible to climb waterfall it
will then be transformed into a powerful
dragon think magikarp and gyarados from
pokemon a lot of things about kaido's
powers are godly including the giant
size of his dragon form and how it looks
as it flies around dominating the
skyline this form is so big it's
believed that he could accidentally wipe
out the entire kudi region of wano in a
drunken stupor i mentioned that the
dragon power allows one to fly around
and that's possible because of the flame
clouds that the dragon can create and
then use as footholds the flame clouds
are strong enough to hold up an entire
island like onigashima another cool
thing about this god fruit is that it
allows kaido to incorporate multiple
elements into his attacks he's not bound
to one element as logia's are we
obviously know about his blast breath
and how he can shoot fire blast from his
mouth he can also summon lightning bolts
with his roar cutting blades of wind
tornadoes and in the one piece video
games even large hails of ice so in the
video games he's even stepping on
yamato's territory a notable technique
he has is flame dragon torch where he
surrounds his giant dragon body with
fire this flame dragon form is so hot it
instantly melts everything it comes into
contact with in order to fight it one
needs to have mastery over advanced
hockey techniques like luffy did if
luffy didn't learn to emit his hockey he
would not have been able to hurt kaido
without physically touching him and so
he would have had no chance against this
form and it's notable that luffy only
managed to take kaido down after he
awoke his fruit and we discovered that
in fact he too had a god fruit the
entire time it took a god fruit to beat
another god fruit in this case which
makes sense so now let's take a look at
this god fruit that helped luffy to beat
the so-called strongest creature in the
world although it was once thought to be
a paramecia called the gomugomi it was
relatively recently revealed that this
fruit is actually a mythical zone called
the hitohito nomi model nika aka the
human human fruit model nika it derives
its name from the sun god nikka and when
the five elders are talking about it
they even say that this particular fruit
has the name of a god but until it is
awakened aka until luffy unlocked gear 5
it primarily possessed the properties of
rubber and so the government succeeded
in keeping its true nature largely under
wraps by labeling it as a harmless
paramecium the government has been
trying to get it for over 800 years but
as a zone with a will of its own the
fruit has been escaping their grasp all
this time once they almost had it before
shanks took it away again and eventually
brought it to where luffy ate it the
five elders described the myth of nika
as follows and i quote possessing a body
with the properties of rubber and
fighting in whatever way he fancies
bringing smiles to the faces of the
people the warrior of liberation also
known as nika the sun god awakening
brings his rubbery body greater physical
strength and freedom it is said that in
all the world there is no power more
ridiculous end quote if you want a
rundown of all of luffy's gears we also
made a video about that but here i'll be
focusing on the awakened gear 5 since it
is the true nature of this god fruit in
this gear luffy is able to tunify
himself and those around him to an
unprecedented degree he's able to grow
his fists large enough so that he can
grab kaido's giant dragon body as if it
was a garden snake as he pulls kaido
kaido's eyes pop out from his head like
in the old cartoons luffy can
effortlessly swing around the giant
dragon banging him into the ground over
and over again not only can he tunify
himself and others he can also tunified
the world around him in one case he
turns the ground to rubber and pulls it
up to deflect tidal's blast breath luffy
is even able to fight kaido from the
inside out and in one instance he brings
his hands out through the back of
kaido's eyes in order to grab his nose
it should be noted that this would
seemingly be much more deadly for kaido
if luffy's powers weren't active and
allowing kaido's body and eyes to
stretch in such impossible and
cartoonish ways but it's all part of
gear 5 luffy having fun at one point
luffy becomes so big that he can use
kaido's giant dragon body as a jump rope
he survives the full brunt of a blast
breath and even flies through the air
after it by moving his legs really
quickly again just like in the old
cartoons he avoids taking heavy damage
from kaido's kanabo by becoming
extremely stretchy to the point where
his nose and tongue take the exact shape
of the spikes of the kanabo he then
dampens the attack of another strike by
making the floor beneath him rubbery he
even punches kaido through the face but
because of toon logic kaido's face is
whole when the attack is finished i hope
it still delivered insane damage though
luffy keeps doing entertaining stuff
throughout the fight like catching
lightning and then throwing it like zeus
using it as a pole to spin around and
even creating a giant hockey infused
fist that even makes kaido's dragon body
look small however oda is not going to
let luffy's victory just be the result
of his devil fruit he has kaido point
out that the best fighters are masters
of haki haki is so important that many
of the strongest characters in the
series didn't even need devil fruits
because their hockey was so strong kaido
then takes the form of the flame dragon
we already discussed and luffy has to
combine his devil fruit power with his
haki mastery in order to actually hit
kaido without touching him and that's
what we saw from the sun god fruit so
far but chances are this is only the tip
of the iceberg since this fruit
represents the freedom to fight however
one fancies still i like the fact that
no matter how ridiculous the fruit is
it's made clear that it's practically
useless without hockey mastery so even
though the fruit seems overpowered luffy
can still continue to become stronger by
improving his mastery over haki which
will arguably be the most important
aspect to him becoming the pirate king
it should also be noted that the sun god
nika figure is a symbol of hope and
liberation for the oppressed and that is
why the government is especially scared
of it it's not just about strength its
very existence may inspire the people of
the world to rise up against the world
government next we turn to the other
mythical human human fruit the hitohito
no me model daibutsu aka the human human
fruit model buddha daibutsu means giant
buddha or great buddha now when we think
about deities of different world
religions we usually think of the buddha
but it should be noted that the buddha
is not actually considered a god in
buddhism still though the buddha is the
central figure we associate with the
religion and you can find golden buddhas
and temples and other places of worship
so for me personally i can see putting
this into the god fruit category as well
the hype fruit also goes to a very hyped
character namely the former fleet
admiral sengoku it's a fruit that even
stands out among the other op fruits the
admirals under him had like the magma
magma fruit and the glint glen fruit the
fruit lets sengoku turn into a giant
golden buddha we can assume his strength
increases to match his giant size we
know little of the fruit for instance we
don't know if sengoku used his hybrid or
full zone transformation at marineford
and we don't know if sengoku had to
awaken his golden form like luffy had to
awaken gear 5. at the very least the
idea of awakening it would go well with
the buddhist idea of enlightenment
however we luckily did get to see the
golden buddha form in action not only
are his physical attacks strong they
hurt luffy even if he puffs up his body
but he can also release golden colored
shock waves that appear to seriously
hurt the blackbeard pirates the cool
thing about this attack is that you can
attack as we saw multiple opponents at
the same time in the anime we even saw
that the golden shock waves are powerful
enough to clash with slash hold off
blackbeard's guru guru no me shockwaves
since the guru gura naomi is considered
the strongest paramecia fruit you can't
deny that the ability to counter it is
fitting for a god fruit the other
confirmed mythical zone fruits although
great in their own right wouldn't
necessarily make it into the mythical
god food category for instance i
wouldn't put the hitohito no me model
onyudo aka the human human fruit model
onyudo here which is onimaru's fruit
because the fruit is based on a youkai
aka supernatural spirit in japanese
folklore but not a god same with
orochi's heavy hebi no me model yamata
no rochi or snake snake fruit model 8
headed serpent which is a legendary
creature but even in its own myth the
actual god in it is the shinto storm god
susanoo a name you may well remember
from naruto and similarly with the other
mythical zones not mentioned here they
would fall more so into the mythical
creature or spirit category than the god
category obviously this is not an
official category yet and may never be
but i think it's a useful one and makes
the actual most op mythical zone fruits
seem rarer and more special and although
we don't have any other confirmed god
fruits i have made videos about
potential other god fruit users in one
piece so let's look at some of those now
blackbeard would be an obvious choice
now there are multiple theories around
having a mythical zone but my favorite
and the one i came up with in my
blackbeard already has a mythical zone
fruit video is the idea of blackbeard's
darkness logia actually being a darkness
or knight or moon god mythical zone to
match luffy's own sun god fruit check
out the video for full details and
quotes that support this theory but to
keep things short if luffy's fruit could
be mislabeled all this time it's likely
that his main antagonists could be as
well the parallels between these two
have been focused on for a long time
with blackbeard representing darkness
and luffy the sun and even their fruits
look very similar having the same color
and spirals once you look at all the
evidence including the fact that
blackbeard's fruit is consistently
stated to be weird for a logia this
theory starts to make a lot of sense and
i'll honestly be a bit disappointed if
it doesn't turn out to be the case
another theory is the one outlined in my
zorro already has a devil fruit video
link in the description people who
didn't watch the video were quick to
comment but he can't swim however the
point of the video is not that zoro
himself ate a devil fruit it's that enma
could have the god of the underworld
devil fruit and so zorro has access to a
god fruit through his sword obviously
this would still let him swim no problem
i won't go into all of the reasons this
theory makes sense here again but it has
a lot to do with how enma is spoken of
in the series in very similar terms to
the way zones are spoken of and also the
way it does things that haven't been
seen thus far from swords it not only
has a will of its own but acts on its
own while zorro tries to tame it and
remember that time when zorro saw the
personification of death and everybody
thought what was that yeah that could
have been the god of the underworld and
perhaps a sign that zorro has awakened
the fruit or is close to it then there's
monkey the dragon if anyone deserves a
god fruit it's this legend it's already
been all but confirmed that his devil
fruit allows him to manipulate wind and
more generally the weather something
that kaido was able to do as a dragon
god i outlined all of this in more
detail in my luffy's that is stronger
than you think video if you're
interested but for the sake of this
video let's go back to the azure dragon
myth the azure dragon which kaido's
fruit is based on is just one of four
dragon gods each of which is associated
with a different direction the oswar
dragon is east while the black dragon is
north the black dragon out of the others
best fits monkey the dragon not only
because he has black hair but also
because the black dragon is also called
the dark dragon or mysterious dragon
both adjectives that fit dragon's
character well if he were to have this
fruit it would easily explain how he was
able to summon both the wind and
lightning that allowed luffy to escape
from buggy and smoker back in the day
and you know his name is dragon which
could be a not so subtle clue although
i'm sure there are people who would say
oda giving a dragon fruit to a guy named
dragon would be two on the nose but
that's why we covered the confirmed god
throughs first and these final possible
god fruits were more so for fun and to
get the brain juices flowing let me know
if you have any other ideas for who
could have a god fruit it definitely
wouldn't surprise me if someone as
important as imu sama had one now
channel the pirate king within and smash
that like button if you enjoyed this one
piece video and want to keep them coming
be a smashing pirate king rather than
passing orochi and rumor has it you'll
get fireworks straight from mono to your
screen let me know what god fruit you'd
want to possess if you had one and who
your favorite god fruit user is make
this the video subscribe if you haven't
already and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one-piece videos and updates
and while you wait for the next chapter
to drop feel free to check out my giant
and growing one-piece playlist that
includes all the videos i mentioned in
this video and much more link to that is
in the description and on screen now
thank you so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys